good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is
scp-1680
object class euclid
special containment procedures site 33b
is to be staffed with foundation
personnel trained in the reception and
processing
of scp-1680 instances site 33b
is disguised as the dilapidated former
location
of mission high school civilians
attempting to investigate the interior
of site 33b
are to be given amnestic treatment and
return to their homes
processing is to be followed by
transport to site-33
previously site-38 for relocation
as determined by site-33b command or the
department of human resources
any individuals inquiring into the
anomalous behavior of scp-1680a
are to be given amnestic treatment when
possible
the foundation is to attempt to acquire
homes within line of sight of the route
of scp-1688 addendum
as of february 11 2009 all human
resources
agents stationed at site 33b are to be
of level 4
rank or higher any foundation personnel
displaying insubordinate behavior in
response to scp-1680 processing and
relocation orders
are to be given a nested treatment and
reassigned
description scp-1680 is a collection of
identical humanoid entities
age estimated at eight years instances
of scp-1680 are 137 centimeters in
height and 38.5 kilograms in mass
upon acquisition because of their
effectively identical nature this
document will discuss scp-1680 as a
collective unit
through genetic testing scp-1680 has
been determined to be an exact replica
of tyler buchanan an eight-year-old boy
declared missing on november 2nd 2007.
see addendum 1681 for acquisition
details
each instance of scp-1680 believes
itself to be
tyler buchanan and possesses identical
memories up to the day of his
disappearance
genetic testing has concluded that each
instance is genetically identical to one
another and to the original tyler
buchanan
each instance of scp-1680 demonstrates
extreme emotional distress when exposed
to other copies
of scp-1680 scp-1680a
resembles a type a chassis short school
bus
bus number 216756
license plate 5pw d314
examination of the chassis and physical
markings suggest it was manufactured
by canadian manufacturer collins bus
corporation
in 2005. no bus matching this
description has been located at any
school
and manufacturing information is not
available
the windows of scp-1680a are effectively
opaque
nothing of the interior of the bus is
visible until each instance
of scp-1680 crosses the threshold of the
door
and exits the vehicle no personnel
attempting to board the bus have been
recovered to date
with varying frequency scp-1680a
appears approximately 150 meters away
from site-33b
drives to the site opens its door
permits an instance of scp-1682 depart
drives approximately 50 meters from
site-33b
and disappears attempts to track the
origin or destination of scp-1680a have
failed
by all collected evidence the bus comes
into existence spontaneously
deposits scp-1680 and disappears
shortly after no individuals living in
the surrounding area have reported the
unusual nature of this to
any official authorities or made any
inquiries to date
to date all instances of scp-1680 have
claimed to have no memory of the bus
ride itself
or of anything between leaving school
and arriving at site 33b
addendum 1681 acquisition log
tyler buchanan was last seen leaving
dresden elementary school in dresden
tennessee
at approximately 1450 hours on november
2nd
2007. while he was scheduled to be
transported by bus number 64
to happy homestead daycare in dresden no
individuals interviewed reported seeing
him board the bus
rather two teachers claimed he left the
building but was called back by a
science teacher to pick up a report card
the science teacher in question could
not be located
the bus itself was never located or
recovered
additionally upon the disappearance of
buchanan and
all of the children on bus number 64
interviews
suggested that all potential witnesses
at the school had gaps in their memory
around the time the bus was boarding
shortly after the bus was reported
missing
anomalous activity was reported from the
school's science lab as well
a cover story reported bus number 64 and
all children aboard
along with tyler buchanan as the victims
of a terrorist attack against a rural
school
the first instance of scp-1680 was
recovered on november 2nd
2007. the foundation had received
reports
suggesting that group of interest lambda
33
mana charitable foundation was
maintaining a warehouse for collecting
anomalous or potentially anomalous
artifacts
at the former site of mission high
school
mobile task force phi 22 was dispatched
to investigate
upon securing and inspecting the area
and determining no lambda 33 presence in
the building
scp-1680a made its first appearance
at 15-25 hours depositing the first
recovered instance
of scp-1680 the instance was presumed to
be a non-anomalous child
transported to the nearest foundation
safe house and questioned
scp-1681 was administered class c
amnestics and was about to be returned
to his home using a cover story when
scp-1688 reappeared six hours later
at the same location and deposited
another instance of scp-1680
both instances were detained while the
mobile task force requested further
instructions
by this time foundation authorities had
determined that an undetermined
anomalous situation had occurred at
dresden elementary school
and that the then unclassified humanoid
entities
were to be detained until further notice
addendum 1680 2 relevant memoranda
205 command from site 33 command
regarding scp-1680 august 28
2008. attached his current documentation
regarding scp-1680
we are currently sitting on 2410
instances of this phenomenon we have
most of them in chemical induced comas
spread around half a dozen different
sites
the few that have died have been
cremated to reduce storage space
but containment is becoming increasingly
difficult in terms of simple quantity of
contained instances
please advise mdj
note no particular answer was given in
response to this memorandum
to all site commands from o5 command
regarding d-class shortage issue october
4th
2008. current attrition rates of d-class
personnel are beginning to threaten
standard channels of procurement
all site command departments are
instructed to compose a report
exploring the possibility of alternate
means of securing significant numbers of
d-class personnel
on short notice 0.52
205 command from site 33 command
regarding d-class shortage issue october
10 2008 report attached
including copy of scp-1680 documentation
protocols
for particular consideration see
attached studies regarding trainability
and
loyalty instances are physically
diminutive but useful for most d-class
tasks not related to physical strength
given the otherwise non-anomalous nature
of scp-1680 iterations
non-anomalous other than the number of
identical copies of instances
we currently believe that the standard
concerns regarding exposure of scp
phenomena to one another are unwarranted
under these circumstances mdj
addendum 1680 2.
dr jones director of site 35 has been
promoted to level 5.
changes in training and orientation for
scp-1680 instances
put into effect november 2nd 2009
for more information regarding the
anomalous event involving the school bus
please consult documentation for
scp-1480
for information regarding an additional
anomalous event connected to scp-1680
please consult documentation for
scp-1380
okay well i think that about does it for
today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
bad luck lou it's not a spoon
corey barker arbiter soul
the morrigan retalias
victoria clarkson azo
aham 5 eric corbidge
justin day kawaii fire keeper
daniel joker corvus
king madding bryson
samurai corgis james saba
and nj vujak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vulcan thank you
you